that could possibly happen how one
anyone could be that irresponsible
and I thought what data was in there
that may compromise sources and methods
by that I mean names of people who
helped or et cetera and it just totally
irresponsible yeah I think it's
disgraceful I mean honest to God that's
all I think what kind of ice cream what
flavor ice cream do you have you think I
would tell you if I knew exactly what it
would be of course I'm not going to you
just come in here with that negative
attitude and it's much too early to make
that kind of decision
foreign
everybody I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report it's January 10 2023 we're
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals and as always uh well as newly
always our post game Wrap Up Show uh is
available available at
reubenreport.locals.com it will be free
for everyone through this week and then
it is for subscribers only so you can
jump over there and you can correct me
if I make any factual errors I'm not
above a correction you can ask me
questions comment on what you've seen
and all that good stuff uh today is
going to be a bit of an extension of
sort of the direction we've been going
in general where there really are sort
of two countries uh evolving right now
and evolving and I would say being
created in very separate paths at the
moment one of them based let's say in
some level of reality I'd like to say
that's the one where we're in we're
freedom and individual rights will
matter and then there's this other one
where a bunch of sort of NPCs
non-playable characters people who just
believe in the machine believe the
government is benevolent and good and
should tell you when you can leave your
house and what you should inject your
children with and whether you should
shop their genitals off uh these are the
directions we're going in right those
are the two things that we have and it's
exemplified
I think at the state level very
obviously and and most prominently by
what's going on here in the Free State
of Florida and then of course what's
going on in my former State communist
California but it's not just States
right because states are just things
they're just sort of collections of
people in Geographic areas but I think a
lot of what's happening right now is
I've often I've talked about it many
times as sort of a spiritual uh issue
and that we need a sort of Spiritual
Awakening because it's not the
government that's going to come save you
but I think you can also look at what's
happening in America sort of at an
individual level that there are
individual people right now who are
doing the right thing and individual
people who are doing the wrong thing so
we're going to start the show today by
talking about two people one of them
doing the right stuff is Elon Musk and
obviously I don't have to go into all of
the good things he's doing from getting
us to Mars and buying Twitter and all
that but basically fighting for free
speech Fighting For The Individual
fighting against the machine fighting
for freedom of thought things like that
and then I want to compare him to uh
Prince Harry now Prince Harry I've
talked a little bit
about the royal family before I always
say like it's not it's not like one of
my main things that I love talking about
the royal family I think there's
something interesting about the crown
actually been watching the the show on
Netflix the crown the idea of a monarchy
that something remains over Generations
over hundreds of thousands of years so
that there is a continuation of
something I think is a is a deeply
stabilizing force in societies doesn't
mean that everything they do is good but
there is some value in that as opposed
to what we have here which is every four
years we just sort of pick a new team
and then all our Norms change right we
had four years of trump four years
abiding it's like this massive flip that
was after four years of Obama there's
there there's something to be said about
a little consistency but whether you are
super rich like Elon Musk or super
powerful and Rich and influential uh
like Prince Harry uh it's sort of
irrelevant What In terms of your life
unless you do something worthwhile with
it and Elon Musk is doing something
worthwhile and I think Prince Harry is
doing something very destructive so I
saw this video yesterday here's how
we're going to start because we talk so
much about Elon Musk here and he's
become so culturally relevant and it
seems like he's sort of the thing that
everything's kind of orbiting around
right now I saw this video which is a
throwback from a couple years ago he was
on 60 Minutes uh talking about his
childhood and I thought this was pretty
interesting to sort of set up who he is
and why he fights for the good things
right now
you grew up in South Africa yes yeah
um I left when I was 17 by myself at a
backpack I close and a suitcase of books
and that's it did you have a happy
childhood no it's terrible
are you serious yes
why was it terrible
[Music]
Elon while he was a little boy
he grew up in a very violent home
like for example when I always had to
drive the car and he would be punching
me and Elon would be between the seats
hitting his father to stop him punching
me my father has a serious issues
um okay well so you didn't have a happy
childhood it was very violent
I do know that you were bullied at
school and had almost been to death if
you'd call that bullied
he was shy and awkward at school Elon
didn't have many friends
pupils at Elon School saw him as strange
and he was systematically bullied for
years
a gang beat up his best friend making
him agree never to hang around with Elon
on one occasion Elon was pushed down a
flight of stairs and beaten violently
leaving him in hospital for weeks it's
no surprise then that as an adult he's a
fighter determined to succeed and prove
everyone wrong
so I did not know that about Elon Musk
you know you hear about him growing up
in apartheid South Africa he's our first
African American African-American
richest man in the world but came from a
tough child it sounds like his father
was extremely physically abusive and he
was bullied and all of the stuff that
many people go through that crushes an
awful lot of people but it seems to have
given him a bit of his fighting Spirit
now I want to compare that with Prince
Harry and trust me by the end you will
see why we are comparing these two uh so
specifically a Prince Harry grew up with
everything right he grew up literally
with a silver spoon I mean they have a
silver spoon that they give the kids and
then the nannies and the wealth and the
fame and all of those things and in
these last few years where he has
married this Meghan Markle he basically
has done everything possible to destroy
the crown to destroy the monarchy he is
talking to the media about how racist
the family is and all of the backwards
things that they've been doing and it's
not to say they should not be criticized
but this is a person who was born with
everything could do a lot of good and
has chosen to destroy the very thing
that that gave him all of the
opportunity in the first place so here's
a little bit of Piers Morgan talking
about what's happened with Prince Harry
and and sort of related to Meghan Markle
once she got in the the family
Regency of all Harry and Megan allow
claims to swirl about racism in the
royal family for almost two years they
made a six hour documentary about it
they accepted a human rights award last
month for fighting structural racism in
the royal family all based on what they
told Oprah Winfrey but now Harry's
decided that apparently that's not what
they meant at all
in the Oprah interview you accuse
members of your family of racism you
don't even well of the British press
said that
right
I did Megan never mention the races
she said they were troubling comments
about what she was concerned about his
skin color right wouldn't you describe
that as essentially I wasn't not having
lived within that family the way the
British press reacted to that was fairly
typical neither of us believe that that
comment or that experience
or that opinion was based in racism how
was she dangerous because of the need
for her to rehabilitate her image that
made her dangerous that made her
dangerous because of the connections
that she was forging within the British
press and there was
open willingness on both sides to trade
of information and with a family built
on hierarchy and with her on the way to
being green consort there was going to
be people or bodies left in the street
because of that so I don't want to get
two in the Weeds on on Megan and what
she said to Oprah and all those things
but in essence they claimed that this
that skin color was an issue within the
family right or were these kids going to
be darker than other people in the
family and everything else they then
accepted an award for going after
structural racism within their family
now he's kind of backtracking but the
reason I'm playing all of that is you
have someone like Elon Musk who came
from a highly abusive family who was
obviously an awkward kid interested in a
lot of things that maybe the regular kid
wasn't so interested in and he became
something incredible and became a
fighter and is doing good in the world
and then you have someone like Prince
Harry who's worth you know he's got to
be worth 60 million you know they say
around 60 million but like it's just an
endless amount of wealth and he runs
around Western media sobbing about his
family and his circumstances and the
racism he comes from and how terrible
the hierarchy of the of the family is in
all of these things but why is this
interesting from from an American
perspective because obviously he's not
American although he's doing a lot of
stuff here and he's a big Netflix star
apparently neither one of these guys are
from America but they both moved to
America to build Empires for themselves
and Elon Musk has done that quite well
and he's taken on the most powerful
forces which is why every day they're
the most ridiculous hit pieces and what
Prince Harry has done is the complete
reverse he is self-flagellated endlessly
told you how horrible the the crown is
how horrible the royal family is how
horrible racism is all of those things
and he's gotten very rich from an
American perspective right so Elon has
done it with virtue and I would say
Harry has done it with Vice and that
made me think of another American guy
there was some guy who actually was born
with a decent amount but he kept
fighting kept fighting for some of the
good stuff never quit never gave up you
may remember him he's Orange here he is
one of the most important things never
ever quit never quit and I've seen
people
quitting
and if they would have held out longer
they would have been successful I've
seen it so much I've seen some of the
most brilliant people in the world that
never made it because they were quitters
they were just quitters they would quit
they would they just couldn't take it
they couldn't whatever now you have to
also have flexibility though
uh you can't necessarily say I'm never
giving up I'm gonna and you gotta be
able to weave and Bob you don't have to
go through a concrete wall you have to
have flexibility you have to always be
able to change course a little bit maybe
always with that same goal but don't
quit
so it's interesting it's not just that
there are two Americas right there there
are very obvious differences between
communist California and free Florida if
you're using those as the examples but
there really are two states of Mind One
is that you can come from a lot or come
for come from a little from abuse or or
have every benefit known to man and you
can go and you can go and you can get
and you cannot quit that is a good state
of mind right that's the state of mind
that I hope you have that's the state of
mind that I think I've generally had
through all of this and there were
plenty of lean years many many lean
years in all of this and I kept going
and kept going and kept going and I
built something right and and that's
wonderful and then there's another type
of person another state of mind which is
you could be given everything and then
you will use that to destroy the thing
and that that is rampaging throughout
the United States right now there are so
many people who are born in all sorts of
privilege and I would say the privilege
is to be an American right to grow up in
the freest place in the history of the
world and to then use that privilege to
destroy it but I wanted to end this
portion of it uh with that Trump piece
because Trump is thought of by by
mainstream as you know he's just the
worst of the worst but what he talked
about right there is something that he
was consistently talking about we've
shown you over the years we've shown you
some clips of him on Phil Donahue and on
Oprah when they thought you know when
that was mainstream stuff in the 80s and
they thought he was a huge star and
literally on Oprah where she's like
basically telling him to run for
president
um the idea that you don't give up you
just keep going you keep building things
and you see what happens and and you may
have to be flexible within that right as
he said you don't run right into the
concrete wall and what do I always say
like you go for that thing but you go
for that distant star you may not end up
exactly there but you might end up some
somewhere approximate to it and that's
probably pretty good so how does the
media
treat people who sort of go against the
grain or go with the grain well as you
know if you just feed the system we
talked about this yesterday this is like
the Stephen Colbert thing if you just
feed the system they will treat you
really well Jimmy Fallon they'll give
you a lot of money you can sort of be
soulless and be a dancing clown for them
but they will treat you well and if you
go against the grain well now you have
the Donald Trump situation or what the
media is trying to do to Ron DeSantis
right now actually right before we
started the show I think we'll cover it
tomorrow New York Times has a hilarious
hit piece on DeSantis that he's worse
than Trump because Trump used to fight
the media but DeSantis is worse because
he's ignoring the media I mean it's just
you gotta you gotta admire the lunacy
from these people anyway let's talk
about a little bit about the difference
of how they treat people because you may
remember in August there was this raid
on Donald Trump's home at Mar-A-Lago and
uh nothing came of it absolutely nothing
came of it and if you also remember when
I came back on the grid with Larry Elder
on September 1st and Larry was telling
me about the whole thing I said to him
you can pull up the video I was like I
don't think anything's going to happen
because of it and then I basically
didn't have to cover it for these last
six months because it was obvious to me
nothing was going to come of it and this
is just what they do with everything
Russia collusion and all of the things
right this is what they do with
everything well now it turns out that uh
Joe Biden has some documents that are
supposed to be classified that were at a
office that is connected to him very
very bizarre but before we get into that
specifically here's Biden talking about
Donald Trump and his documents and the
Mar-A-Lago raid from a couple months ago
you saw the photograph of the top secret
documents laid out on the floor at
Mar-A-Lago what did you think to
yourself
looking at that image
how that could possibly happen how one
anyone could be that irresponsible
how could this happen how could anyone
be this responsible this is insane these
are classified documents this is serious
stuff oh well happening to Biden right
now
sources tell CBS News the classified
documents were discovered in this
building about a mile from the White
House at the offices of the Penn Biden
Center a foreign policy Research
Institute set up after President Biden
left the vice presidency according to a
source familiar with the matter the
classified documents are small in number
and were found in November in a box
among unclassified material sources
would not characterize how sensitive the
documents are
responding to requests from CBS News the
White House Council said that on
November 2nd of last year before the
midterm elections lawyers for President
Biden were cleaning out office space at
the center when they discovered the
documents marked classified in a locked
closet they stopped the work and
contacted the White House
of course right before the election they
found this sort of thing now look when
the Mar-A-Lago thing happened I knew it
was all nonsense and nothing was going
to come of it just like impeachment one
and impeachment 2 and impeachment for
three scoops ice cream and impeachment
for holding the glass of water with two
hands and all of that stuff you do have
to acknowledge and this is the key part
I think the difference in the way the
media will cover these leaked secret
classified documents versus Donald
Trump's but I know that's not a surprise
to you right you're not going oh my God
I really thought they were going to be
equal 50 50 on this thing of course they
won't be also uh let's not pretend that
Biden had anything to do with this I
mean Biden is just so not even in charge
he's not in charge of putting his shoes
on right so the idea that he was
personally doing this stuff however the
buck does have to stop with someone and
that's why people eventually up top have
to be taken out like you're in charge of
the operation but the point is if this
if a scandal is going to take down Joe
Biden I think there's far worse scandals
to take down Joe Biden just yesterday we
talked of about the story how the
administration was directly and they can
link it basically up to Biden from an
email that they were censoring Tucker
Carlson on Twitter at the behest of the
Biden Administration like that's
impeachment level stuff so I don't know
that anything's going to come of this
but I think it's just worth making a
note that when it was Trump
all hell was going to break loose this
is the Smoking Gun we finally got him 87
other impeachments orange man bad and
this one of course will just basically
be ignored but let's talk about
something that maybe won't be ignored
because it is it is so tangible that the
media is actually starting to come
around to it I'm talking about the
border so you may remember let's go back
to the orange man for just a second he
wanted to build a wall right and when
people said that you want to build a
wall that means you're obviously racist
well uh now Joe Biden after several
million people have just strolled into
America you know we cover it NBC does
not cover it New York Times does not
cover it blah blah blah finally Joe
Biden went down to the border and here
he is is just a little short video and
tell me if this is a guy as you see him
walking around does this guy seem like
he's in charge or knows where he is
come on come on the shelter
they just throw them down there they
throw on The Aviator Shades they say Joe
just walk don't say anything just walk
okay so he got down there and what's
interesting is that you may remember a
couple weeks ago there was this video
going around of the El Paso Airport
where there were dozens if not hundreds
of illegal immigrants sleeping on the
floor and in the bathrooms and wandering
around outside and nobody really cared
about it AOC didn't tweet about it now
when you know 30 of them get to Martha's
Vineyard all hell breaks loose okay fine
but he was in El Paso uh Joe Biden so
what did they do before he got there
yeah they they cleaned it up because you
can't have the elderly man pretending to
be president seeing a bunch of illegal
aliens on the street I mean that would
that wouldn't be fair
of course this area it was had a lot of
police presence we've been reporting in
the past couple of weeks of police
coming here they've been arresting
people for maybe paraphernalia they had
access to to marijuana those types of
arrests we spoke to one woman we asked
her have people been cleaning this area
in preparation for President Biden's
visit one woman did tell us that yes the
city Chia seen City officials or city
employees out here cleaning the area in
preparation to President Biden's visit
I love that they're cleaning it up just
for Biden right because you wouldn't
want to Biden to see the the disaster
that reminded me did any of you guys go
to sleep away camp and you guys go to
sleep boy Camp yeah I remember in
Sleepaway Camp you know when I was there
when I was you know fifth grade sixth
grade whatever it was that right before
uh parents visiting day they would do
like two crazy days of cleaning like for
weeks before that you're living in filth
there's food everywhere and garbage and
whatever it's amazing like in sleep wake
up it's awesome but then right before
the parents get they clean it up the
parents come everyone's like oh this is
great it's all good the money money well
spent that's basically what they're
doing here well then he shows up in
Texas uh they barely gave any warning to
Texas governor Greg Abbott and Greg
Abbott decided to show up at tarmac here
he is you'll see Air Force One behind
him uh and he is not thrilled with this
Joe Biden fella so this
that the president who caused the chaos
of the Border needed to be here it just
so happens he's two years at about 20
billion dollars too late
he needs to step up and and take Swift
action including reimbursing instead of
Texas for the money that we spent but
providing more resources for the federal
government to do its job also this is
nothing but for show unless it begins to
enforce the immigration laws already
that exist in the United States of
America that are contained in the letter
that are provided to the president today
what did he say to you what did the
president say to you you said he wanted
to work with us
again Abbott got basically no
notification all right he shows up at
the tarmac there he's in a wheelchair
probably not the easiest thing to do in
the world okay fine that's one thing but
what he says there at the end is the
important part it's not as if right this
moment we need a whole slew of new laws
right everyone wants the government has
to do more and we need new laws and give
me more paper to print and all of this
stuff and how about we just
go with the laws that we have how about
we just make sure that you can't just
wander into the country that is breaking
the law by definition but the Democrats
obviously want that they obviously want
that the mayor of El Paso who is a
Democrat which is very bizarre to me but
who knows uh he went on CNN and uh you
know basically uh he's not happy that uh
Biden didn't get to see what he should
have seen mayor one question has been
about what the president didn't see
because from our reports on the ground
reporters who are with him he didn't
actually come face to face with any of
the migrants there and we know that
there are hundreds of migrants of course
we've seen them sleeping on the streets
of El Paso so did he get a sufficient
view of the humanitarian crisis aspect
of this
he did
I could have played you more of the clip
but he didn't because they cleaned it up
before he got there he then went to the
Salvation Army over there in El Paso and
I think it was the militant wing of the
Salvation Army if I'm not mistaken
that's an Austin Powers joke if you're
following uh he went there and just try
to make sense of what we may have to
play this one twice please make sense
this is at the Salvation Army in El Paso
he's there for immigration he walks up
to one of the people there over at the
Salvation Army and someone explained to
me what he's saying here
all right we got it we got to play this
one again and because it's a little hard
to hear but it's really important so
he's at the Salvation Army he is told he
is at the Salvation Army he's meeting
people from the Salvation Army he walks
up to that man and says that he quote
spent some time with the Secret Service
in Poland and Ukraine and then that man
from The Salvation Army has to oh well
my god well that's play it again please
as Connor just pointed out you know the
guy did have a big S badge on his
shoulder there so it's possible that Joe
Biden thought that meant Secret Service
it probably meant Salvation Army but
like there's something wrong with him
there is something wrong with it well
there's a lot of things wrong with this
man but like literally does not know
where he is okay anyway here's noted
black lesbian press secretary Corrine
John Pierre just lying about what's
going on here the president inherited a
mess because of what the last
Administration did they herited we
heritage the president inherited a mess
these are the same exact people who
every time Donald Trump said we have to
have a border and then we can figure out
what to do with the dreamers meaning the
people that are here the young people
who were born here and everything else
and a pathway to citizenship and we've
covered this many times Biden uh sorry
Trump was willing to negotiate with the
Democrat everyone knows it like you
without even knowing all the specifics
you know that when Donald Trump was
President he would have cut deals to
deal with the immigration situation and
deal with the people who are here
already and the dreamers and everything
else right there's been a lot written
about this the Democrats Chuck Schumer
is on the record saying they did not
want to give him a win right they did
not want to cut a deal with Trump
because they did not want Trump to be
good to be thought of as positive and
they certainly did not want him to be
re-elected well uh Nikki Haley who was
Donald Trump's U.N secretary right the
ambassador to the U.N from the United
States and then also of course was the
governor of South Carolina she heard
what Corrine Jean-Pierre said and she
tweeted this out so she's you can see
she's retweeting the original video that
we just played right there and she said
here's the border crossing mess that
Biden inherited in 2020 458
000 uh illegal people crossed over in
2022 I'm not a math the magician but
it's about five times that two point
roughly 2.4 million people don't listen
to this Administration spin when Biden
goes to the Border tomorrow the mess
he'll see is one he created and of
course that is true and that is why we
must fight the media lives and that's
why we must not forget what they did to
Donald Trump and the way they treat him
versus what they are doing and the way
they now treat with kid gloves the
elderly man pretending to be president
but let's let's now get this to uh sort
of the bigger version of what I started
so I started with that there are people
trying to do good in the world right and
it doesn't matter what they came from
whether it was abuse or
Financial despair or whatever but there
are people who try to do good I would
put Elon Musk in that bucket there are
people who were born with everything who
then just want to destroy everything for
attention or for whatever woke thing
that they're worshiping I would put that
with Prince Harry but other people that
we could relate this to uh well one of
them more in the Prince Harry Buck it
would be California governor Gavin
Newsom so here is a tweet from Gavin
Newsom about this border situation
president and this is just a couple days
ago President Biden is right from day
one of his administration Republicans
have failed to even discuss our outdated
immigration system it's long past time
for them to engage in finding real
solutions now of course this is
hilarious because I don't know if Gavin
Newsom knows this he does know it it's
just that he's incapable of saying a
single word of Truth the Democrats have
been in charge of everything until a
couple days ago now the Republicans have
the house so the idea that if Nick
Avenue is now saying there is a border
problem and he's blaming it on the
Republicans makes no sense right it only
makes sense in his fictitious world but
of course it's funny because we found
this video in just a few months ago he
said that the Border crisis was made up
altogether this whole damn border debate
is made up
it's made up
oh it's made up because could we go back
to his tweet because that's what he said
a few months ago and then his Twitter
President Biden is right from day one of
his administration Republicans have
failed to even discuss our outdated
immigration system but he just said it
was made up
lordy lordy uh Gavin Newsom was
inaugurated for winning his re-election
a couple days ago he gave a speech
um it was the most dishonest
pandering driveless woke crap
Factory of a speech you've ever heard uh
well here's some of it
all across the nation anxiety about
social change has awakened long dormant
authoritarian impulses calling the
question calling to question what
America is to become Freer and fair
or reverting to a darker past
they make it harder to vote and easier
to buy illegal guns they silence speech
fire teachers kidnap migrants subjugate
women attack the Special Olympics and
even demonize Mickey Mouse
all camouflaged under the hijacking of
the word freedom
trying to be nice but the things that I
want to say about him I should just
write the things down and then I'll put
it and then I'll fold up the paper and
I'll burn it in the backyard later that
would be the better way to deal with
this emotionally he's so evil he is he
is just evil you know I say it all the
time it's like I don't know what exactly
the human soul is but I think it is
somewhat connected to truth like the
thing that separates us from the animal
from the animals the idea that you wake
up and you have thoughts that we have
cognition and can put truth into the
world and and set a world that is filled
with order and decency and goodness he's
the reverse of that I don't think the
man has a soul everything that he said
he's worried about the Republican
authoritarian impulses this is the guy
who completely demolished California
through lockdowns that he ever even says
the word free as if he cares about
Freedom now it is interesting that
somehow when he was locking down
everybody in California the area where
his Winery is and he's worth you know
hundreds of million dollars his Winery
he was able to stay open when he locked
down everyone else's wineries but he's
talking about Freedom that's right that
that we've made it harder to vote he's
really trying to talk about Florida here
no we have we have by far the most
secure elections yeah you do have to
show an ID unlike in his State because
you don't have to show an ID there
because they want everyone to be able to
vote and they want the fraudulents baked
in that it's easier to buy illegal
weapons he said uh if a weapon's illegal
you can't buy it you douchebag and
um yes we have a second amendment
whether you like it or not and demonize
Mickey Mouse I mean do I have enough to
start like he's just such an absolute
clown uh I was on Fox this morning I was
on Dana Perino and Bill hemmer show and
they were asking me about what's going
on you know this this contrast between
Cali and uh and Florida and we we
actually crunch the numbers I busted out
the Abacus the Reuben report Abacus
carried the one did all the math uh in
the last three years California has lost
975
000 people that's 275 5000 in 2020 360
000 in twenty twenty one three hundred
forty thousand in twenty twenty two that
is almost one million people nine
hundred and seventy five thousand people
and I have to remember these people they
leave and who who are the people that
are leaving these are people who are
producing these are people who are have
businesses and who are putting their tax
dollars back into the system so he can
do all his stupid pet projects like they
are actually taking resources and
they're leaving and where are they going
well then they are going and they are
taking their resources and their
families and their value and they're
taking them to Red States and then red
States get stronger economically
culturally spiritually Florida has
gained over eight hundred thousand
people in the last three years twelve
hundred people a day move to the free
state of Florida and I know that that OG
Floridian with the cigar in his mouth
wrestling the alligator on uh you know
hole 18 that he was worried that they
were all going to come in and bring all
that blue State [ __ ] but people have
not done it and you know they we know
that because DeSantis won by 20 points
Rubio won by a landslide and everything
else so what else is going on here what
else is going on here well we've got
some info from Florida's voice Governor
Ron DeSantis awarded a total of 79
million for high performing Nursing
education programs in Florida 60 million
of the award has been distributed to
school districts with licensed practical
nursing programs 20 million and Florida
college system institutions with
licensed practical nursing and
Registered Nursing programs 40 million
through the pipeline program these
Awards will meet a critical need of our
state by ensuring we continue to have
high quality nursing graduates and by
creating new opportunities for for
Floridians interested in health care
said Governor Ron DeSantis so do you get
it what DeSantis is doing here is
exactly
what he did what was it about a year and
a half ago with police right he saw what
was going on in New York and in New York
they were not back in the blue uh they
were firing people because of vax
mandates and everything else so he said
hey if you're an officer up in New York
and you want to move down to Florida
they started giving out cash bonuses
they started restructuring things so
that they could figure out because we do
back the blue here and that's why
Florida has record low crime Miami I
think was voted I think it was about two
weeks ago the safest city in the United
States despite as I even referenced this
we've got Miami Beach here we've got all
of the Spring Breakers here occasionally
there's some weird stuff that goes down
and still we are the safest city in the
United States we've got more from
Florida's voice Governor Ron DeSantis
appointed new leadership at new College
of Florida to overhaul the institution's
equity ideology for a merit-based
approach The Daily Caller first reported
the governor announced six new
appointments to new College of Florida's
Board of Trustees appointment T
appointments include Chris Ruffo Matt
Spalding Charles Kessler Mark barlin
Deborah Jenks and Jason Eddie Speer as
Governor DeSantis stated in his second
inaugural speech we must ensure that our
institutions of Higher Learning are
focused on academic excellence and the
pursuit of Truth starting today the ship
is turning around new College of Florida
under the governor's new appointees
appointees will be refocused on its
founding mission of providing a
world-class education with an
exceptional focus on the classics Brian
Griffin the press secretary for governor
DeSantis reportedly said in a statement
so it's happening guys that's what I'm
trying to link just like individuals
Elon Musk doing it right Ron DeSantis
doing it right and then the things that
they're part of whether it's Tesla or
Twitter or the great state of Florida
start flourishing then we start bringing
in better police officers because we say
will back you here and our crime goes
down we start funding nurses more where
other states are literally firing nurses
for not getting mandates and they still
have all sorts of problems related to
that in New York and in Michigan and
Cali and everywhere else and what are we
doing we're putting 65 million dollars
towards having better nurses here so you
can do it and you're all a part of it
you're all part of it in your own way
whether
in your mind right now that's still
being in a blue State and fighting I
just don't see how that can work anymore
but there is there's worth in fighting
I'm a fighter I never realized in my
life that I was a fighter until all of
this craziness with covid and then
campaigning with Larry Elder for the
recall and everything else or it's
whether you move and then and then
reinvigorate a place that you move to be
appreciative of the people who did it
right who who left you with a a refuge
of safety a little Oasis a citadel of
Freedom as DeSantis calls this place and
this is the battle that we are up
against and it's a it's a political
battle but it's also an individual
battle and we found this video of Jordan
Peterson talking about since we just
talked about universities and what's
turning around here in Florida this is
Jordan Peterson talking about how
radical leftists have destroyed our
universities and actually accomplished
nothing at the exact same time because
we have all these radical left political
activists departments at the
universities women's studies being at
the top of the of the list that have
done nothing for the last 30 years have
done nothing but produce an never-ending
stream of
ideologically-minded
counter-civilization political activist
heterosexuality that's a tyranny
capitalism that's a tyranny democracy
well that doesn't even exist and even if
it did it would be a tyranny it's
nothing but a tyranny in the in the eyes
of the of the radical women's studies
types and what would they replace it
with they replace it with their own
ideological Utopia well we've already
had 100 Years of that we saw what
happened oh well that doesn't matter
that wasn't real Marxism that's what the
bloody marxists always say it's like oh
how many millions of people have to die
before you're convinced that it's real
Marxism and I know what they mean by
that too they mean hey if I was the
Marxist dictator things would have gone
a lot better it's like uh you should
think again sunshine
man he's so good he's so good no matter
how many times we play Jordan Clips or
how many dinners I have with him or
events that I do with him like he's just
he's just he makes me want to be a
better man
um so the choice is yours guys right
like if we were doing this in another
Jordan version of this it's like you can
either clean the world or you can clean
your room you have a chance to do both
but you got to start by cleaning your
room and most of these people who are
constantly what he describes I love this
phrase counter civilization activists
that's what they are it's easy to burn
down so which is easier which is easier
if you were going back to the top of the
show which is easier is it easier to be
Elon Musk or or Harry Prince Harry
it's obviously easier to be Harry Harry
grew up with everything and then what
did he decide to do with it he decided
to burn down the institution that gave
him everything Elon grew up and I did
not know this until this morning in this
highly physically abusive family okay
and then what did he do he learned how
to be a fighter and that's why he's
fighting right now like you have to
connect those things that kid who was
beat up and beat by his father and
watched his father beat his mother for
some reason he has the spirit of
fighting now as a he's probably about 50
years old something like that he has the
spirit of fighting in him so when when
he buys Twitter and then and then sees
all of this [ __ ] around it and sees
what the government's been doing with
these counter civilization activists who
work there he's fighting so you can do
it so you can either be a good person
you can be like Ron DeSantis and say I
will be a leader I will do what is right
I will strengthen the communities around
me and all of those things or you can be
a bad person you can be a liar and a
fraud like Gavin Newsom you can actually
point to goodness and tell and tell
people that it's evil
suppose the choice is yours what are you
guys going to do you guys can make a
choice on that you want to think about
it over lunch all right over lunch I'm
going to talk about it with the team
we'll get you guys know what I'm doing
but I don't want to put words in their
mouth so
we'll discuss it over what are we having
today over Sushi we're gonna have a
little Sushi and then we'll decide if
you guys want to be good guys or bad
kids that's good
for the rest of your lives
uh guys the post game show uh will be at
reubenreport.locals.com uh in just a
minute or two we've got a cold close for
you in just a sec part one of my
interview with Tulsi gabbard where we
really got into some stuff we really did
you know I know the main concern for a
lot of you as she's evolved politically
and let's say come over a little more to
our side is where is she at on guns I
ask her that absolutely directly and a
whole bunch more of the full things up
ad free at locals right now uh we got a
cold close for you and then I'll get
some comments and questions locals
exclusive which as I said for this week
only will be open for everybody and then
it's going to be subscribers only uh
going forward
see you in uh what did we say 42 seconds
the impact what happened
on July the 6th had International
repercussions beyond what I think any of
you can fully understand
[Music]